On nous a annoncé d'incroyables nouvelles sur le Royaume.
Il paraîtrait, qu'au Sud, une femme serait devenue reine.
Il paraîtrait aussi qu'elle a des dragons.
Et...
Qu'elle est très, très, très, très bonne.
Et aussi une armée de morts-vivants de glace qui se dirige vers nous, accessoirement.
Exact.
Y a ça aussi.
Yorel a une grande nouvelle à nous annoncer.
Yorel ?
On a capturé...
Un marcheur blanc.
Mais attention, hein !
Un vrai mort-vivant de glace de la légende et tout.
Si on découvre comment tuer ces créatures...
On pourra aller à la capitale.
Et avoir des toilettes perso !
C'est le moment qu'on attendait tous !
Les mystères sont de mise, mon pote !
Elle est bien cette devise !
Mais ouais !
Ouais, ouais.
Alors, ça a pas été de tout repos.
Mais j'ai réussi à apprendre à la créature à parler notre langue.
Au début, c'était un mort par-ci, un mot par-là.
Et un jour...
Il a fait une phrase entière.
On était tous là, genre...
Qu'est-ce qu'il a dit ?
Allez vous faire enculer.
Ça a été ses 4 premiers mots ensembles.
Si j'avais pas ces chaînes...
Je vous découperais en morceaux !
Et je vous éparpillerais en forme de...
- Spirale !
Spirale ! C'est spirale. On sait que vous aimez bien faire ça.
Vous pensez vraiment mériter de finir en spirale ?
C'est les bonhommes qui finissent en spirale.
Vous méritez même pas de finir en cercle !
Ah si, si ! Vous mourrez en cercle !
En cercle !
J'ai pas compris l'insulte.
C'est froid.
Alors, ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que les marcheurs blancs n'utilisent pas d'argent.
Du coup, on a dû trouver autre chose.
Bon, marcheur blanc, si tu nous dis comment vaincre tes frères...
Nous t'offrons...
Cette tarte aux pommes.
Ce joli dessin fait par Yorel.
Une hache !
Mais non, non.
Une bougie parfumée.
J'ai trouvé que ça.
Ah, ouais, ouais.
Il a accepté de nous dessiner son point faible...
En échange de 3 plumes de perroquet...
Un demi sandwich à la dinde...
Et de ça...
Niquel !
Du coup, on a fait venir un seigneur de la capitale...
Pour lui parler de notre découverte.
Il paraît qu'ils ont trouvé une solution...
Pour vaincre l'armée des marcheurs blancs.
Ça pourrait tout changer.
Après, pour moi, ça reste des clodos.
Le loup siffle un chant de miséricorde.
Le lion et le cerf se côtoient de nouveau.
Les gens de la capitale se la pètent beaucoup.
Dans ces cas là, on envoi Yorel...
Pour dire bonjour en 5 phrases, il est imbattable.
Les effluves de la rancoeur des lions...
Ne peuvent soutenir les années perdues...
Dans les rivières des tours ventues
Pas mal.
La truite a, certes, navigué dans des eaux houleuses...
Mais ses écailles restent vigoureuses.
Ok.
Mais ses écailles peuvent-elles soutenir la patte d'un lion furieux ?
Oh !
Place les mystères sont de mise, bordel !
Mais j'essaye là !
Bon, on gagne ou pas là ?
Y a 3 - 2.
Pour qui ?
Je sais pas.
Bon, allez, allez ! Go, go, go !
Si parfois la tortue....
N'aime pas le lait...
Alors, la bonne nouvelle c'est que pour les tuer, faut les planter avec ça.
La mauvaise nouvelle, c'est qu'on a aucune idée de ce que c'est.
Je me casse.
Là, on espérait vraiment pouvoir gagner la capitale.
Mais finalement, on va rester ici un peu, ouais.